I'm Cristin youth president of the
American Enterprise Institute and I'm
delighted to welcome you all here this
afternoon for this seminar entitled will
derivatives cause the next financial
crisis this is the first in a series of
seminars research seminars that AEI is
organizing as part of our new program in
financial market research that will
focus both on financial markets and
their regulation I'm delighted that
professor Franklin Edwards who's Arthur
burns professor at Columbia University
and one of the nation's leading experts
on financial market regulation who this
year is a visiting scholar at AEI has
not only organized this series but is
prevent presenting the first paper which
he will discuss this afternoon following
a professor Edwards presentation
James Bothwell at the u.s. General
Accounting Office will offer a reaction
and discussion and then we will turn to
a general discussion from the floor well
with that I'd like to turn things over
to Frank Evans
thank you Chris and welcome to the AEI
today's topic is provocative will
derivatives cause the next financial
crash with such a great turnout and I
suppose that some of you think that one
of us at least is going to say yes you
may be disappointed however that I don't
think Jim is going to say that and I
don't think I'm going to say that but we
are going to say quite different things
another way of posing the same question
is our derivatives the nuclear waste of
financial markets capable of causing a
financial market meltdown and less
tightly controlled by government and
regulation perhaps in attempting to
answer that question I should start by
saying what I am NOT going to say and
then say what I am going to say what I
am NOT going to say is that there are no
problems with how derivatives are being
used I am also not going to say that
there is no possibility that losses
associated with derivatives could cause
or precipitate a financial crisis such
as we might have almost had in October
1987 and I am also going to say that not
going to say that there is nothing we
can do to improve things what I am going
to say is that the fears and concerns
have been associated with derivatives
have been greatly exaggerated the same
risks dangers that are present in
derivative markets I hope to show you
today are present and most other
financial markets as well and that these
risk can be as well managed in
derivative markets as they can in any
other financial
I'm also going to say that derivatives
are in fact the highly useful instrument
for managing risk and on net probably
have reduced the risk of a systemic
meltdown by permitting a more efficient
spreading of risk throughout the
financial system and finally I'm going
to say that to the extent that any
systemic risks exists and of course
there's always a systemic risk any if to
the extent that it exists the Federal
Reserve's powers as lender of last
resort I believe are capable of heading
off the financial meltdown at the
conclusion I will also make a few
suggestions about things we might do to
improve how the market works my
objective today however is to take you
on a little journey through the
derivatives minefield to see if I might
we together might not be able to
demystify the controversy about
derivatives so that when you leave here
today you will have a broader
perspective I hope on what the issues
and controversies are all about let's
begin with the question why is everyone
so concerned about derivatives you can
see that from what I am going to say
that I'm not terribly concerned about
derivatives but am i out of step with
everybody else well let me give you some
suggestions about why everybody is
concerned I think there's a great deal
of mystery about these markets the names
themself swap options caps floor inverse
floaters and we could go on and on our
words that I'd say the man on the street
simply does not understand and in fact
even if you've had an MBA at Columbia
University ten years ago you probably
didn't run into any of those concepts in
getting your MBA so this is a relatively
new market and it's inundated with very
esoteric terms secondly complexity it
seems very complex
take the Procter & Gamble swap at least
what I understand to be the Procter &
Gamble swap Procter & Gamble agreed to
play of pay a floating rate interest
calculated as follows
you take the five-year Treasury note
rate multiply it by seventeen point zero
four five and then subtract from that
the price of the outstanding 30-year
Treasury bond with a coupon of six point
two five percent now you might ask
yourself why does a company which make
soap need a transaction like that so
it's definitely complex and mysterious
third substantial losses have been taken
in this market in the last twelve months
if I add up the ones I've seen correctly
I get something like sixty two billion
dollars have been lost maybe I have that
number wrong I'm not sure it seems very
high
of course someone had games to that
amount to during that time pay we have
to keep that in mind but that's still a
lot of money to lose in some cases these
losses were very great for example the
14th largest German firm medica
shell-shocked mg lost about 1.5 billion
dollars taking it to the brink of
bankruptcy we have to keep in mind that
if mg had gone bankrupt their
counterparties some of our most
distinguished firms JP Morgan for
example might have taken some losses in
addition to that the Deutsche Bank had
substantial existential equity interest
in mg so the deutsche bank could have
taken losses so if a large firm indeed a
sophisticated firm like that could come
so close to the edge of bankruptcy
because of some losses in derivatives
maybe their estate and finally there's
the GAO study
which was released last May and which
certainly received worldwide attention
and it suggested I believe let Jim speak
for himself that OTC markets could pose
a serious risk to the entire financial
system because a large OTC dealer or
end-user of swaps could default causing
a domino like meltdown in the system in
reaching this possible conclusion the
GAO emphasized the enormous size of the
over-the-counter swap market or the OTC
swap market the extensive dealer
concentration in this market and the
gaps that currently exist in the
regulation of these viewers and then
finally the extensive worldwide linkages
that could threaten or would threaten to
quickly transmit the financial
disruption from one market to another
and in fact transmitted worldwide I have
passed out to you a sort of a handout if
you look in your booklets you will see
that there are about six or seven tables
in there I'd like you to look at tables
one and Table four
what table one does looks like this
what table one does is it simply gives
you a estimated breakdown of the
magnitude of these markets of course
it's also useful because it focuses on
just what we mean by derivatives but if
we look at that briefly we can see that
derivatives are divided into
exchange-traded futures and options
derivatives off exchange or what we call
over-the-counter forwards and also off
exchange swaps and then with a few
rather esoteric instruments like
mortgage derivatives structured notes to
fill to round it up altogether it has
been estimated recently at least this
number could be as high as 35 trillion
dollars 35 trillion now that's a very
large number and it suggests that this
market is growing enormous Lee it's very
large and if it's that large there could
be serious risks here if we look at
table 4 what table 4 tells you is that
these are the 15 major u.s. swap dealers
essentially and you can see who leads
the list the Chemical Banking
Corporation Citicorp JP Morgan Bankers
Trust Company the Chase Manhattan Bank
Bank of America and first Chicago so all
of our major banks are deeply involved
in these markets and if you look at the
size of their positions Chemical Bank a
trillion and a half now that sounds like
a lot of money to be tied up and just
swaps after all this is a very small
part of the banking business so the fear
therefore is that the size of this
market being as large as it is and
growing as fast as it has been carries
important and serious risk which we must
address and then finally that those
making the swap market the dealer is the
bank
are just a handful of very large firms
which hold most of the positions what
would happen if one were to fail so to
speak okay well what are derivatives
anyway what do we mean by derivatives
well the common definition is that a
derivative is an instrument whose value
is derived from the value of some
underlying instrument a futures on crude
oil futures on crude oils simply derives
its value from the underlying value of
crude oil when the spot price of crude
oil goes up the value of that futures
contract Rises when the dye of crude oil
goes down the value that futures
contract goes down an option on the S&P
500 index the stock market when the
value the stock market goes up the
option value goes up
however these and I'd say traditional
derivatives forwards now futures options
are not really the center of the
controversy now the center of the
controversy is the over-the-counter
derivatives market which is largely the
swap market and we saw on table 1 that's
the bottom part that's about the 8
trillion amount so we have large large
swap Mar market made by a handful of
very large banks both in the US and
abroad and some security firms and
insurance company affiliates as well
okay well what I'd like to do is take
you through an example of how swaps are
used what they're being used for their
attempt to demystify this whole thing
and what can go wrong with a swab to do
that I'd like to first draw your
attention to chart 1 now what chart 1
does it simply sets out a very simple
plain vanila balance sheet of a small
Bank SRB small regional bank and you can
see that it has loans of 3 million
security such as maybe government bonds
is holding of 1 million some cash of 1
min so total assets of 5 million
and on the other side it has deposits of
three million and a few other
liabilities and some equity essentially
what this Bank is doing is what most
banks do it is raising money through
deposits taking deposits and using it to
make loans more than that it is usually
raising money on a short-term basis with
deposits maybe every three months it's
paying a new deposit rate depending on
what rates do and it's lending that
money out long perhaps for five years or
three years or even longer at a fixed
interest rate that's a typical sort of
banking transaction what are the risks
that this Bank is exposed to well it's
very clear that if it lends the money
out at seven percent and is paying four
percent now it has Court of us it has a
three percent interest margin their net
interest margin but what happens if
interest rates begin to rise four five
six seven eight the bank could find
itself in the situation where its cost
of money was more than the revenue from
its loan which would soon eat away its
capital and finally bankrupt the bank it
has what we call market risk or interest
rate risk the risk that interest rates
will change it also has that risk and it
holds any asset like securities interest
rates go up the value of securities go
down eating away at the capital this
would look very much like those of you
in Washington remember the thrifts used
to look right and they had this problem
- well a firm like this will typically
use a swap to eliminate that market risk
so it's going to use the swap to
eliminate that market risk and how is it
going to do this
let's look at table two it's going to
perhaps go to one of the dealer's we
just looked at JP Morgan and do a swap
with JP Morgan and how's it going to do
that well since its receiving a fixed
loan rate and paying a floating rate it
can get hurt if interest rates rise so
what it wants to do is get paid
something when interest rates rise to
offset that risk okay so the regional
bank is going to
to pay the dealer a fixed rate of
interest and it's going to ask the
dealer to pay it a floating rate of
interest which will float upwards as
interest rates rise so if interest rates
go up to 4 from 4 to 5% the bank will
receive more money from the dealer but
goes up to 6 even more and of course all
the income will be used for is to offset
its higher interest rate costs as
interest rates go up this so the whole
point of this swap is to insulate the
bank from the interest rate movement now
what happens in table 2 is this it
enters into the swap it will do is a
swap of a with a notional value of 3
million it means that the dealer and the
small Bank agree that they're going to
set some principal amount to the swap
it's called the notional amount 3
million and from that it's going to
derive interest flows and these interest
flows will be will be determined by the
rates they agree on so what happens is
the regional bank here agrees to pay JP
Morgan a fixed rate of 4.5% a year on a
notional value of 3 million so if you
want to know what the periodic payment
would be each year I'd say it would be
four and a half percent times 3 million
okay it in return it will receive from
JP Morgan the the Eurodollar rate which
is now we'll assume is at 4%
- 0.5% sort of a dealer Commission in
there now let's assume what let's what
Table two does is just take you through
what happens when interest rates change
the middle column there no change in
rates represents what happens after the
bank enters into the swap agreement and
rates do not change well you can see the
top 3 rows 7 - 4 3 what that is is it
the bank without the swap received 7
percent on its money pays 4% on the
deposits 7 percent of the 3 million
dollar loan 4 percent pays on the
deposits for a net interest margin or
profit of 3 percent what do the flows
look like a de swamp now that's the next
two rows
the fixed amount they agreed to pay is
4.50% so that's the - 4.50% but the bank
receives the Eurodollar rate which is 4%
- a half a percentage point so it
receives 3.50 percent for a net cost of
the swap of minus one now you add those
up and you get a net margin with the
swap of two percent so what's what's
happened here if the interest rates
don't move the bank is worse off than it
would have been before because it's
going to make a profit of now only two
percent instead of three percent but now
let's see what happens when interest
rates move let's say interest rates rise
by 300 basis points reaper centage
points that's the column on the right
well if that were to happen you can see
that what changes the cost of money they
have to pay seven percent on the
deposits which would have wiped out
their profits but the swap now pays them
six six and a half versus the four and a
half they have to pay so they're ahead
on the swap by two and somewhat
miraculous you see at the bottom line
they have locked in there two percent
properly with that swap going the other
direction rate sleuth let's go down by
three percent yes they would have been
much better off at rates fallen because
they would have been able to refinance
that lot that loan at lower deposit
rates they would have made much higher
profits but the swap takes some of that
away just enough to have them come out
with the same two percent so what they
have done with the swap is they've
completely eliminated that market
interest rate risk they have locked in a
profit margin of two percent their cost
of doing that was one percent but they
have no further interest rate risk now
if you think about that what's the most
prudent way for a firm like the small
Bank to behave to take the risk of
interest rate changing where they could
make more money if interest rates go
down or go bankrupt possibly if interest
rates go up or a lock in a profit well
many of us would say that the prudent
way to behave would be to lock in that
profit with a swap so here's a case
where the swap
actually reduced risk and that's the
point that is what firms are doing with
these instruments they are reducing risk
they are reducing interest rate risk
they're reducing currency risk and that
is a very prudent thing to do so that's
the value of a swap now of course what's
the risk here well the risk that could
occur is suppose when interest rates go
up and this small Bank is to receive
these payments from the dealer the
dealer in fact defaults and so now the
bank has taken will take its loss on the
rise and in trade
and will not be able to collect from the
dealer in other words the small bank has
credit risk against the dealer of course
if the if interest rates go the other
way and therefore the bank would have
small Bank would have to pay more than
the dealer then the dealer will be owed
money the dealer will have credit risk
visa be the small bank so credit risks
exists in this market but the first
principle to note here is that the
magnitude of the credit risk is far
different from the notional value of
this deal the notional value was three
million in the event of a default one
firm is out only what they are owed on
the payment which would be something
like the difference between the fixed
rate and the floating rate times the
principal let's say one percent of the
notional value so the default is not
that the the counterparty that is has
the credit risk and losses if there's a
default doesn't lose the full three
million but perhaps loses 1% of the
three million so the first thing you
want to get from this is that the extent
of the credit risk has no direct
relationship to the notional value of
the thoth of the swaps that are
outstanding so when you look at nine
trillion dollars or 37 trillion dollars
it doesn't tell you a lot about what the
risks are in the system that's the first
principle the second principle is that
what would happen if the bank
the borrower of the bank had defaulted
the borrower the $3,000,000 say it was
one borrow three million dollar borrow
if that borrower defaults what is the
bank's credit risk is it the difference
between the fixed and floating no it's
the principal and E so in a typical loan
transaction the default risk or what we
call counterparty risk is far greater
than the default risk is on a swap of
the same notional principal so second
principle is that the credit risks in a
typical balance sheet are usually higher
with respect to instruments other than
derivatives the third principal as I
said before is that without the swap the
small bank here has tremendous interest
rate market risk with the swap it
doesn't okay so that all seems very good
well what can go wrong with this swap
well many things can go wrong first of
all when they put this the bank that put
the swap on could have been inept didn't
know what it was doing put the wrong
swap on okay they're gonna lose money
yes they're going to lose money if they
buy the wrong security make the long
long wrong loan or put the wrong swap on
that's right what else could go wrong
well I could show you I won't do it for
the sake of time but table 3 works out
an example where the small Bank does the
reverse swap instead of receiving
floating and paying fixed the bank does
just the opposite it decides to pay
floating and receive fixed in that case
the bank takes a pure specular position
more or less doubling its risks so these
instruments can be used in two ways they
can be used to reduce risk but they can
be used to accept to increase risk
dramatically if you want to but of
course that's nothing new either we can
take positions in securities we can take
positions in loans we can take positions
in liabilities which can increase risk
too
so derivatives are a double-edged sword
like almost every financial instrument
you can take a lot of risk with them or
you can reduce risk it depends on how
they're used they're not used prudently
you can get into trouble if they're used
in eppley you can get into trouble well
with these with this in mind let's look
at the kinds of risks that are a great
concern now in the controversy that is
kind of raging about these markets well
the first one is the magnitude of the
market and I've already hinted at where
I'm going with this the magnitude of the
market is not really a relevant index of
the risks that exists in this market and
what I like to point out to you is I'd
like to go to chart 4 which looks like
this and what this is is an estimate of
the credit exposure
of the ten largest banks and you can see
that it compares the derivatives
exposure with the loan exposure and you
can see it's far less and of course it
also contours it compares it with the
total assets so the same principle as
I've been talking about is extraneous
diagram if you look at table next table
table five figure five I'm sorry you
will see something like this and what
this is is a breakdown of each of the
major banks and it shows in the white
box their loans and it shows in the
black box the derivatives as and both as
a percentage of the equity of the firm
and what you can see is that the credit
exposure on the loan portfolio is almost
always considerably higher for even
these banks which are the most active in
derivative markets than the derivative
exposure so this kind of puts it in some
perspective the GAO study suggests in
their work that the credit exposure is
on the order of 1% or less of the
notional value from these markets so the
first thing is the concern about credit
exposure in these markets based on a
notional values is really almost
irrelevant now in addition to that I
would say and I think Jim will agree
that firms are very aware of this risk
this is not a secret the risk that our
risk that firms taking derivative not a
secret to them they're well aware of it
they've been working very much on their
risk management systems and as far as we
can tell from what we know is that they
are managing this risk prudently and
have systems in place to do it and if
they don't have a perfect sitio a very
good system in place they're working
very hard to do it the second major
concern about this market is that there
are unregulated entities in this market
and here I think again the perspective
is not completely the major players in
this market are the banks banks are
highly regulated especially the
derivative activities they must hold
capital requirements derivatives they
must have in place crude management
systems
they must have implicate and you know
we're working on accounting and
disclosure principles which would expose
the risks as well the requirements that
are being asked of the banks in this
area are in fact much greater in my view
than the requirements against their
other activities so I think we're really
ahead of the curve on regulating
derivatives activities of banks relative
to the other activities of banks that
the traditional vector these are banks
the other dealers in the market security
firms and surance County fields are less
regulated but I don't think they should
be regulated there's good reason to
regulate banks banks after all have
Deposit Insurance they have certain
public guarantees they must be regulated
insurance company affiliates security
firms they are regulated by the SEC and
by state insurance companies but I'm not
terribly concerned about regulate
regulating them because I don't feel
that they're being protected by public
guarantees like the banks are so not
it's not that they're unregulated but I
don't worry about there not being enough
regulated enough regulation if they fail
that would be too bad but I don't think
they carry systemic risks with them and
I don't think it's a tax payer problem
well it should anything be done in this
market you can seed it where I'm coming
out on this is that it sounds pretty
much like I feel everything's fine and
that not only will derivatives not cause
an exponential crash but in fact this
market is functioning pretty well and
there's little we can do well I would
say I would just give you three things
that we can do one I've said that banks
are regulated they are but of course
there
we have to do more refining of the
concept of how you measure bank capital
and how much capital should there be
these are not easy questions everybody's
aware of them all the regulator's
throughout the world are hard at work in
answering those questions the banks
themselves are hard to work and
answering those questions
we don't have probably the full answer
right now but I think we've made a lot
of progress and we're rapidly making
progress I think we're going as fast as
we can in that area better disclosure
statements and better accounting very
difficult issues I think again we're
making tremendous progress in this area
and I think it will be very very short
time where we have very elaborate
disclosure statements on the risks being
taken the Fisher Report when a group 10
the New York Fed I think goes a long way
towards doing this and finally for
mutual funds and I didn't mention mutual
funds well one of the causes of one of
the reasons for concern about
derivatives is of course that the loss
is taken by mutual funds in particular
money market mutual funds where Bank of
America and Payne whoever had to bail
out their money market funds I think
it's pretty clear we need risk
disclosure statements that are
understandable by really not terribly
sophisticated investors I don't think
anybody disagrees with that I think
again the problem is in the operational
sense how to do it it's not easy to
convey the risks that you take in any
financial instrument so I think that
everybody is aware of it we're moving
towards it and I would not say I do not
think banning these instruments is the
right thing to do because I've just
shown you how they can be used to reduce
risk and do other good things I don't
think that's the answer I think making
Bester's aware of the risk they're
taking is the answer and that's the way
to go well in closing I really you know
probably want to do two things I want to
point out that you know first of all I'm
not the only person who believed this
I'm a member of a group of
the financial economists roundtable I
have not passed a statement out but this
is a statement signed by 33 leading
academic economists for Nobel Prize
winners and essentially that statement
is fairly close to what I think so I
think anybody who wants to copy that
I'll be glad to give it to you and then
finally although I don't want to I don't
want to end on a note that that sounds
trite I do want to end with a passage
from Shakespeare which seems fitting you
must you probably noted in the paper I
passed out that my paper was titled the
derivatives much ado about not too much
and of course it's easily imaginable
that my title I wanted to put an is what
to do about nothing but I thought that
might be going a little far so I put
much ado about not too much so in that
spirit I have taken a passage from much
ado about nothing act 2 scene 3 and
rewritten it slightly I think to fit the
modern world and I think captures my
conclusions although a little more
flippantly than I really would like to
convey them for you but here goes it
goes like this
sigh no more seers of derivative crises
sigh no more derivatives are deceivers
ever one foot in risk and one in profits
to one thing constant never then sigh no
more but let them soar and be you right
and bonny converting all your sounds of
woe into hey nonny nonny thank you Jim
would you I think Chris is leftist so
I'm the moderator and probably means I
can cut you off at will
thank you very much Frank I like to
welcome both Frank and AEI to what has
rapidly become the great derivatives the
bay of 1994 and depending on the outcome
of the elections tomorrow maybe of 1995
as well I don't know if you've checked
the information in my brief biosketch
that's in the package but if you if you
had you see that prior to entering
government service 17 years ago I had a
very brief stint as an academic
economist and so those of you who are
economists certainly know the theory of
human capital one of its basic tenants
is that over time human capital like
physical capital tends to depreciate
others once you know that you're
listening to a very rusty old machine up
here but truthfully it's been several
years now that begins saying that I used
to be an economist not anymore
now with the amount of time I've been
spending talking about our derivatives
report I'm starting to see I used to be
a government executive and now I feel
more like a lecturer on a derivatives a
seminar circuit but I'm not too far
removed from the academic circle to have
forgotten all what used to be called the
tricks of the trade and one of them was
as I recall that you in order to make a
convincing paper or make a convincing
presentation he set up what were called
strongmen but I had sort of forgotten
what the definition was so I got out my
my dictionary at work and I looked up
the strongman and it was defined to be
one set up that's an opponent to be
easily defeated or refuted and as I was
reading Frank's paper which I've been
asked to comment on a touch too much on
it today but as I was listening there's
your marks I I kind of think that the
GAO report has been set up as a straw
man in terms of it's really some
misrepresentations and mischaracterize
mischaracterizations of what our message
really is about derivatives so what the
risks car and what we think need to be
done to see that these risks are better
managed and overseen so basically today
I would just like to very briefly go
over what the main Gao message is in our
report I brought along a copy there's
other copies outside the door if you
want to pick one up on the way out
please please do so then I would like to
talk about a couple areas of agreement I
think exists between Frank and myself I
think there are a couple areas of
agreement and then finally talk about
some areas of disagreement in this area
and I think there's probably more areas
of disagreement than agreement but and
then finally a few words on the
situation that franked alluded to and
talked about at the end of his paper
with regarding the German firmament a
ghazal shaft basically there's four main
major points that we're making in our
report on derivatives and in our
testimonies before Congress first is
Frank alluded to is we think that
there's a need to close what we're
calling regulatory gaps in this market
others have referred to them as
regulatory black holes if you look at
our reports there's a chart I don't have
any handouts here with me today but
there's a chart on page 11 of that
report which really lays out what we
think these regulatory gaps are and when
we talk about closing these gaps we're
not talking about frankly the to tightly
controlling the entire market we're not
talking about a comprehensive bank like
regulatory structure very costly
regulatory structure what we're talking
about is imposing or having imposed upon
major dealers and the Frank talked about
handed out in the handout talking about
fifteen major US dealers just on those
major dealers three basic pillars of
regulatory oversight and those basic
pillars are an annual examination of the
risk management system there's no
dispute here that derivative products
are valuable and useful
and if we didn't have them we probably
have to invent them for much the way
Frank Illustrated for the you stuff
small bank to make a it's mitigate its
interest rate risk but derivatives
products have to be managed and used
properly right now the 15 major dealer
sevens are seven are banks they do have
annual examinations as Frank said
there's also those five u.s. securities
firms and three very large US insurance
companies so that where they set up
their over-the-counter derivatives
dealing in unregulated affiliates so
there are no annual examinations
independent exams going on their second
the second basic pillar is consistent
capital standards that reflect all the
major risks in derivatives and although
the paper and the comments today are
almost exclusively focused on credit
risk by no means is credit risk the most
important or significant risk in this
market there's also market risks of the
exposures to different positions and
losses that could be suffered from
changes in interest rates foreign
currencies or equity prices there's also
legal risks involved with this market
are very significant and operational
risks as well and liquidity risk again
as we point out in our report it's only
the seven bank dealers there are subject
to capital standards and mostly the
capital standards are almost exclusively
credit risk oriented regulators were
supposed to come up with a capital
component for interest rate risk but
they haven't yet done so and so all the
other types of risks are essentially not
being inflected well in capital at all
even for banks and no capital standards
exist for the securities firms and the
insurance firms in this in this market
third the third pillar of financial
oversight we think need to have
reporting requirements and although
report point out in our report and in
the chart that reporting requirements
exist for banks and securities firms and
insurance companies the type of
reporting that we're talking about
really doesn't exist for any
and what we're talking about is
regulators having current accurate and
centralized information on the positions
of all major over-the-counter dealers so
that if a crisis does develop in the
derivatives perhaps because there is
activity perhaps because of some other
component in the overall corporation
regulators will know who is exposed to
whom and more perhaps more importantly
who is exposed to what types of risk
them terms of market risk and right now
that doesn't exist the closest thing
that we have there is in the CFTC and
there the future future Commission
Merchants have to report daily on their
large positions but right now having
that current up-to-date real-time
information on on positions I just
doesn't exist and certainly doesn't just
mean centralized format today our second
major point is the need to improve
corporate governance among both large
over-the-counter dealers as well as
major end-users of complex derivatives
and this is our only point that concerns
the end users of derivatives basically
we recognize and appreciate that
corporate governance is the first line
of defense in this area and what we're
essentially calling for here is that the
management of firms to self assessments
of their risk management systems over
their derivatives activities and report
the results of these assessments
publicly right now this is required for
banks under the fascia law of 1990-91
there is no similar requirement for the
other major derivatives dealers and
indeed there is no similar requirement
for major end-users account of complex
derivatives it is not accurate to say as
it said in the paper that this would
require some great expansion or
enlargement of SEC Authority we believe
and SEC believes we're in discussions
with them they already have the
authority to require this for public
registrants through disclosure and in
that fact this has been
proposed in the past even before the
derivatives came to be such a hot topic
that public registrants do annual
assessments and do public reports on the
adequacy of the risk management systems
finally the SEC in order to implement
this would have to set out some
guidelines for the responsibilities of
directors we think these it's very
important that the directors of major
dealers and major end-users be
knowledgeable about derivatives project
products know why they're being used
know the risks that are involved and so
the SEC should set out some guidelines
for the directors in this area similar
guidelines been put out by the bank
regulators and they've been put out by
the ball committee on international bank
supervision as well as IOSCO which is
the international group of security
market regulators so again what we're
asking for here is not very much indeed
I don't think and indeed many of the
major derivatives dealers are doing self
assessments of their risk management
systems after the group of 30 report
came out last year a lot of them to
their credit went down that list of
benchmark or best practices and use that
to judge the adequate adequacy of their
own systems and and allegedly made
improvements all we're asking is that
the results of such assessments be
reported to the public thirdly we're
asking for improved accounting and
disclosure for derivatives when we
looked we found that there were no
authoritative accounting rules over
swaps and options and there was a great
deal of flexibility and hedge accounting
rules so that indeed we thought there
was a real possibility to financial
reports could lead to misleading and
inconsistent results what we did there
is to urge the financial accounting
center in this country faz B to consider
adopting a market value accounting model
for all financial instruments it's
incorrect to say paper said that we
recommended that it be implemented
and that we were short on what the
specifics would be we recognize that
there's a lot of issues that badly needs
to work out and we're helping that as we
work them out particularly issues with
regards to how much volatility you might
put into balance sheets if you had
market value accounting for all
financial instruments you recognize this
is different difficult it's easy to say
much harder to do but what we're really
urging them is to go ahead with their
market value accounting project and
finally we think that there is
insufficient disclosures with regards to
derivatives particularly with the
amounts at risk they've recently put out
faz 119 which is going to require
greater disclosure about information on
the types of derivatives products
corporations are using and the reasons
that they're using them as well as more
information on gains and losses and and
at least for the derivatives held for
trading on the average value over the
reporting period but there's not going
to be in our view it's sufficient
requirement to disclose the amount at
risk with regards to derivatives
activities and and another project that
we're doing related to foreign
regulatory systems over banks I recently
learned that in France every large
French bank is required to place in
their annual report a one-page summary
called market risk and then on that one
page it will tell you and this is as of
the end of the reporting period so it
has those limitations but it will
clearly tell you how much that
institution stands to lose if there's a
ten percent change a hundred base point
change in interest rates there's a ten
percent change and specific foreign
exchange rates or if there's a decline
in equity prices so right there on one
page the public investor can see what is
the appetite for risk for market risk by
that institution if it's good enough for
large French banks we wonder why it's
not something we could do in the United
States as well
our fourth major point in our report is
the need to harmonize regulations and
standards for accounting disclosure and
capital internationally this is an
international business we need a level
playing field
but such harmonization shouldn't be at
the cost of us weakening our own
regulations and standards as we say we
think they need to be improved
first of all with regards to the two
areas of agreement I think exists
between Frank and myself one is about
the nature of the over-the-counter
derivatives market it's a large market
regardless how you how you measure it
it's a rapidly growing market although
the demand for at least for some certain
exotic derivatives have probably been
chilled by the by the recent losses that
have been reported it's a global market
and it involves few very large dealers
and over-the-counter products and also
the over-the-counter market has
established linkages among the dealers
the small community of dealers among
dealers and then users and among the
over-the-counter markets and
exchange-traded derivatives and really
the only point that we had and we talked
about the concentration in the market
and this is one example we looked at to
get away from notional amounts we agree
entirely with the Frank's critique of
notional amounts we only indicated use
them as indicator of how rapidly this
market has grown but when we looked at
the concentration of credit exposures
and US banks the seven large banks
account for 90 percent of the credit
exposure in over-the-counter derivatives
for all US banks so there's a few very
large players and but that was really
the only point that we had been talking
about concentration Frank and his paper
sort of makes Lujan's a reference to the
fact where the concentration and the
over-the-counter dealing market is not
much different than the concentration
that exists in the in the government
securities dealers market there's two
points I'd like to make they're number
one
government securities market is a highly
regulated market there's examination
there's capital their sales practice
rules and his custodial rules and that
market now that the second point perhaps
the more important point is that that
market is a strictly dealer market so if
one of the dealer gets into trouble and
perhaps defaults it doesn't affect the
value of those financial assets it's
still the US government standing behind
US securities however in the
over-the-counter market if a dealer
defaults it's not only a dealer at
function they stand as the counterparty
and if you as a holder of one of those
Goods contract with that dealer and they
default and they owe you money then your
stand of a risk of loss in that
situation so it's quite a bit a
different situation
the second area I think we agree on is
the numbers about this industry and
they're less than less than perfect
frank handed out the numbers at The Wall
Street Journal
put out in August to update the numbers
we had in our report the numbers in this
paper are saying numbers in our report
based on in year 92
those numbers are horribly out-of-date
and research assistants update update
those numbers and even if they are
updated one of the curious things about
this market that shows the lack of
reporting is that the numbers for the
global players at least and the swaps
component which Frank frankly pointed
out is a component of most interests at
times is totally from self reporting
it's not required reporting it's all
self reporting through a trade
association and reporting response isn't
100% so those numbers aren't aren't very
good at all in that area with regards to
the points of disagreement we have I
think the main one I would take issue
with both in the paper and in the
discussion is the relative importance of
credit risk and the likelihood that what
will trigger a systemic crisis is a
default by a counterparty or may
your dealer as I said there's five major
risks in this market credit risk market
risk legal risk operational risk and
liquidity risk of the five credit is the
only really measurable one it's the only
one you have numbers on we have the
numbers in our report and you can take
down that those trillions of dollars in
notional in the one to two percent of
credit risk but I think it's wrong to
put the emphasis on credit risk here
it's probably the least important of the
risks as Frank said the dealer's seem to
be doing a very good job of managing
credit risk they typically deal with
investment grade counterparties if they
get into the money to any great extent
they starting to take collateral and
they also have netting requirements
across their counterparties more and
more and I used to say that therefore
they're perhaps the best manage although
I'd like to note that there's a very
interesting paper that was just
published by or put out by Gregory Duffy
at the Board of Governors of the Federal
Reserve which claims that the
traditional methods the measuring credit
risk are understating credit risk by
amounts of at least 20% and these are
traditional more carlo methods but I
really feel that if one was to ask me
where a systemic problem might come from
would it be credit risk I would say no
but I really think it would probably
come from and they're not making any
prediction here prognostication that's
beyond my mission at the GAO it would
probably come from the market risk and
that that would be the likely trigger
for any for a systemic problem because
you might very well have a situation
right now you don't have the information
to know where several of these small but
large dealers are all taking positions
on the same side of the market perhaps
they're all thinking that interest rates
are going to to fall or to rise or that
equities in a rise or fall or that some
be some general market movement and
foreign currencies and they could be
wrong and the market could move against
them and in that situation you're gonna
get you know if that occurs you will
have several major dealers perhaps
perhaps a major end users on the long
side of the market you could get
concurrently significant losses and that
may trigger a series of defaults but the
point there even if it does then the
defaults are going to be positively
correlated as you can get several
defaults and our fear is this is one of
the thing that Duffy points out in his
paper that the supposition is that
counterparty defaults will be
independent events and they're not you
probably aren't going to be independent
events there's gonna be some market
shock this is gonna cause some losses
and the losses are going to be suffered
by many of the market to submit at the
same time and this also occurs in
reference to to our pointing out that
the big bank dealers in terms of their
credit exposures to derivative their
multiples of their equity capital
positions and the critique is that well
their equity capital will only be wiped
out if all their counterparties go down
as if they were independent events the
exact point is that they won't be
independent of events it's much more
likely you have several counterparties
in trouble at the same time this is a
market shop having said that I really
don't think a financial crisis requires
federal intervention he's gonna come
through a chain reaction of defaults I
think it's Mike much more likely to come
from a problem with liquidity in these
markets much has happened after the 87
crash a large number of these products
these more exotic derivatives if you
will are not even tradable on markets
they're very customized instruments and
the ones that are traded the market is
and all that all that liquid to begin
with even with the recent experience of
Kidder Peabody and the losses and CMOS
and that really had a dramatic effect on
on the liquidity of the CMO market so I
think you're much more likely if there's
a market break or some kind of
exhaustion and Shaw
you don't know where it's gonna come
from to what you're gonna find is a
number of players in this market
substantive some losses and they'll
withdraw from the market and what will
happen then will it be like the 87 crash
there's no problem with the banks in the
a7 crash there was a problem with
securities firms they had lawsuits they
couldn't measure how how large those
losses were the Federal Reserve had to
intervene to get the banks to provide
liquidity to the securities firm because
unless they did whole payment system was
going to go into gridlock such a
scenario you can think about with
regards to derivatives I believe but in
addition to liquidity risk and market
risk there's also a substantial legal
risk and I don't want to take up too
much time here we do well the time for
for questions and more discussion but I
do note that even the group the the
director of the group of 30 report
Charles Taylor at a recent conference
noted that legal risk is a very
significant risk we think it's a
significant risk about 20% of these
deals are done with the of the of the
deals done by that large us dealers are
done with foreign dealers it's not clear
at all whether or not there's a
bankruptcy situation overseas whether or
not these netting agreements are going
to be upheld in court you won't be able
to find that out until it really happens
so even Charles Taylor notes that legal
risk involved with these markets has
greatly enhanced a systemic risk and
there's significant operational basis as
well as well so I'm really quite puzzled
as to how one can conclude as the paper
concludes that the concerns with regards
to the riveters are at a portion to the
actual risks associated with the OTC
market I have no idea what the asset the
actual risks are I know what credit risk
are and I'm not concerned with the
credit risk I'm concerned with the other
risks
I think we also disagree with the
quality of management in financial
institutions as I said one of our main
points is we think you need to improve
corporate governance in this area both
for large dealers and large end-users
the paper says that these are all big
large successful so far financial
institutions that are dealing in this
market and that there's no evidence that
they're not well managed and there's no
reason to be concerned let me give you
just a partial list of reasons Kidder
Peabody Solomon brothers Drexel Burnham
Prudential securities bank of New
England first city first city I said it
twice because it failed twice and a bank
insurance fund that went from a positive
balance of 18 billion dollars to
negative seven billion dollars in four
years
the swing of twenty five billion dollars
maybe it's because of the unique
perspective of our agency my academic
capital is depreciated but my
inside-the-beltway capital is been
rising over the last few years but all
these cases and certainly I'm not saying
that they all derivative related though
some are but certainly a major component
of them was a failure of corporate
governance and a failure of their
internal control systems so that's why
we think it's so important that you have
an outside independent review of the
risk management systems in this very
large market these products are very
complex and hard to understand and you
need public reporting for the results
and indeed the only case where you have
that occurring is with the bank and we
know that because there's bank
examinations as I said and when we look
at the bank examinations for the large
banks involved with derivatives dealers
for two years or two years we looked at
1992 we found very major problems but
the examiners talked about with regards
their risk management
very basic thing failure to set or to
follow risk - failure to do stress
testing failure to document the trades
so the only case where you have an
independent verification there's
problems and yes if you went around and
we talked at all 14 or 15 big dealers
and yes they do describe improvements
that they made to their risk management
system we can't verify them no one is
verifying them except for the banks so
part of our message is don't take it on
faith there's a lot at risk here let's
have some independent verification and
public reporting finally the last area I
want to talk about and it's not
surprising given that we're at AEI I
think we disagree about the role of
government and the potential for market
discipline in this market basically
Frank and his paper and as remarks
implies that's the only role for
government here is to protect assured
deposits it's the only mistake that the
taxpayers have I think that's confusing
the the ends and and and and the means I
think the end for the federal government
and its primary goal does maintain
stability in the financial system
Deposit Insurance is one means to that
end but I think if you look you will
find that preserving civility in the
financial system was just as much a
reason for setting up the Federal
Reserve in 1913 as it was for setting up
the FDIC in 1933 I think that's the
overriding role for the government in
this area and indeed as I already said
up to the 87 crash the Federal Reserve
intervened
not because the banks were in trouble
not because there was a threat to
insured deposits they intervened because
it was a threat to the stability of the
financial system the system holes went
into gridlock they had the lien on the
banks to provide the liquidity and
securities firms and also I believe
there's a reference in the concluding
part of Frank's paper about the
likelihood of a meteor striking earth as
if the possibility of a derivatives
problem overflowing and develop and the
financial area was that remote
I don't know how remote it is we never
said in our report and I've never said
publicly that we think derivatives has
increased systemic risk I don't even
think that's the right question
we have no metric to measure it's just a
mess I don't know that anyone that does
but in our in our project we pretty
early on decided that wasn't even a
relevant question the relevant question
is that there is systemic risk and it's
exactly the function of regulators to
worry about those low probability
high-cost events that is what they are
paid to do and that is what the
taxpayers should expect them to be doing
to make sure that those high costs don't
get transmitted to the taxpayer okay
fine finally just to wrap up about
Metallica chef if you read Frank's
description of that case and I really
have nothing to add to that I have no
information about what really happened
them with regards to Michelle's chef but
if Frank's description is accurate and
have no reason to believe it's not
accurate you really see that they are
essentially is a great example of why
our recommendations need to be
implemented because what you will find
there is a story where the management
had no idea allegedly what was going on
with the use of derivatives had no idea
what the strategy was they had no idea
the products or the extent of the risks
exposure you also find a story about how
the accounting rules are seriously out
of sync between the United States and
Germany I don't know if that's true or
not
but one of our things is a harmonized
accounting rules and to increase
corporate governance as well thank you
very much Jim is this microphone on yep
well rather than meet taking all the
time to respond I'm gonna throw it out
to your questions I'll just say one
thing since it's really central and
that's this question about where we
stand on government
which is a one of the last things you
alluded to I couldn't agree with you
more that the main objective of
government regulation is financial
stability where we disagree is what you
have to do to maintain stability and my
position where we really fundamentally
and philosophically different my
position is that if we maintain the
stability of the banking system and the
Federal Reserve acts in its lender of
last resort capacity as it did in the
1987 crash that's all we need
and we shouldn't get into micromanaging
every firm Under the Sun and in the name
of financial stability so we differ in
that respect but before we you know I
don't want to answer I don't want to
take up any more time because I know
everybody here is burning with questions
so why don't we open it up and questions
yes I think we'd like to identify the
questioner
so who has the microphone yeah oh great
Neil Pearson US Securities and Exchange
Commission for mr. Bothwell what exactly
does the GAO anticipate that the
regulator's would actually do with
real-time information on derivatives
positions well what they would be able
to do is is what they scurry around and
try to do in almost any crisis situation
which is find out who is exposed who do
I call who's in trouble and if you look
at these past financial crises and we're
gonna have a report coming out in the
next few months on several of these
define just basic information about
who's in trouble and who's not who do I
call what I do at the 87 crash it was a
question who had the power to shut down
the stock market
they would be able to know if there was
a market shock in exogenous shock who
might be in trouble they would and I
think there's also a public good aspect
to this I don't think it's any player in
this market has an incentive to deal
with somebody who's not properly
managing their own risk but the problem
is you could control your who you deal
with in your counterparty whether you
don't know who your counterparties
counterparty are so I think even the
industry would have a benefit if there
was a referee here that someone who's
very very exposed an extreme position
extreme leverage position in the market
that the regulator's good could call and
ask a question about that do the
directors of that firm you even know
about this exposure do they think they
have the managed well I think there's a
role there as well on this question of
director liability directors I think we
should just sort of set the record
straight directors are already liable
you know for mismanagement for
negligence for fraud for all kinds of
things and I'm not quite undone I'm just
a little confused as to exactly why we
need government controls to make
directors responsible
we have stockholders that are supposed
to do this and we have lots of laws that
are supposed to do this I don't really
see where derivatives need any special
treatment there do anything else the
firm is doing yes standpoint of the
liabilities of Directors and management
of the firm particularly in the
multinational area these people have the
responsibility to maximize profits now
the question is what guidelines are we
talking about should the president of
the bank in your description I mean
should he try to maximize the profits of
the bank in order to do a derivative
which might benefit his bank to a
greater extent than just keeping the
risk protected or in the international
area where you have multi national
currency problems how do you define
these risks when doing a swap which
would just remain or keep the status quo
might be very detrimental to the
corporation itself can you just identify
yourself yeah I'm a bill asking of
debbie's you asked of income right good
well I'll respond to that I think if we
view it instead of maximizing profits we
say maximizing shareholder wealth
because then that that entails an
element of risk and you can easily see
that if in the pursuit of profits you
take wild risks and the stockholder
let's say for the moment are aware of
those wild risk you might have your
stock going down not up
so the answer is yes to have that they
do have a responsibility to kind of
maximize profits but with some
perspective on risk or to maximize share
value now what I think Jim and I both
agree on is that to make that market
work effectively we need good accounting
and disclosure of the risk and we have
no difference of opinion on that
the only question is exactly how to do
it and Jim alluded to a system of a
French system of having a risk
disclosure statement let me tell you
what is being proposed is far more
extensive than that for our country what
is being proposed is not only market
value accounting on the balance sheet
you know income state but as special in
addition to those two statements risk
disclosure statement which could turn
out to be very elaborate and you know
one of the ironies of this whole area is
that the derivatives often get attacked
but in fact many of the same risks as I
pointed out or have been present for
hundreds of years and bonds and stocks
and everything else and yet we've never
demanded a risk disclosure statement
suddenly now we're asking for what
academics would consider to be
incredibly good risk disclosure
statements and that's to the good so I
think I would say derivatives I've had a
terrific healthy effect here on looking
at the entire financial information
being produced by firms so if we can get
that done which will not be an easy task
then I would say the market would work
effectively in controlling risk well
that's yet no I would just add that
whatever risk disclosure is being made
and referring to is proposing it well
the Fisher report the fisherman part of
the group can in the Federal Reserve
Bank of New Zealand that it done just
not be derivative I mean that would be
backwards you want the whole sense the
market risk of of the entity that's
what's being proposed that's what the
fishery where it does get by derivatives
are used as a hedge right but the
interesting thing about it is that
derivatives have sort of stimulated us
to revisit the entire financial
disclosure of the entire firm and I
think we're coming up with a lot more
sophisticated reporting than ever before
it's another question yeah could you
identify yourself
sue Simon at Capitol insights group this
is sort of a two-part question do you
think part of the losses in the last 12
months have been related to two
derivatives related to mortgages
mortgage-backed securities and others is
that been a peculiar feature of it and
do you think if the Fed continues to
increase rates it seems to be the bet
that we will continue to to see more
losses because there were lots of
derivative bets made on on these
interest rates not being where they
might be at the end of the year but
point to a large percentage are products
and I think the public policy issue
there again our report but a public
policy issue there is certainly related
to disclosure the fact that money market
funds entitled US government securities
fund has volatile CMOS in it and the
best scooters are experiencing losses
because of the volatility in interest
rate markets I mean though the SEC is
very concerned about that and they're
trying to actually get more authority to
require more disclosure from the mutual
fund so that is an area where they
probably do need more authority
someone's surprise to me but now I think
you are gonna see more losses before tea
and I don't worry about it fit I mean
look if you look at the firm's and lost
money they were speculating speculators
make bets sometimes when it about
interest rates going up and sometimes
buddies rates going down sometimes they
win and sometimes they lose their that
will always be the case whether they
lose in fixed income securities
mortgage-backed security CMO inverse
floaters is irrelevant and yes if
interest rates continue to go up there
will be people betting and it's trades
aren't going to continue to go up and
they will lose money on the other hand
there will be people betting that
interest rates are going up and they
will make a lot of money I just don't
think that's a concern of the United
States government
I'm Tony van whitson with macneil/lehrer
Newshour and I'd like to ask a question
of mr. Bothwell you talked about the
need for greater disclosure disclosure
is also an issue that's come up in some
of the lawsuits that have been filed
filed by some of the big losers in
derivatives in particular Proctor and
Gamble and also Odessa college both of
them were claiming that there wasn't
enough disclosure between the dealer and
the end user do you think as a matter of
policy there should be more disclosure
there or do these people just have to
take their lumps well there's two types
of disclosure issues with regards to the
Procter & Gamble and Gibson there's also
filed suit against Bankers Trust I think
they were the first ones to file suit
against the Bankers Trust and Procter &
Gamble the issues are whether or not the
Bankers Trust disclosed all the risks in
the business contracts that they sold
and did they actually even disclose the
market value of those contracts they
after it was signed
and there's also disclosure issues with
regards to Proctor and Gamble and Gibson
whether or not they made the proper
disclosure and their to the SEC and
again there's allegations that they were
misled by Bankers Trust in terms of what
disclosures that they would have to make
they bought contracts so there's several
disclosures issues involved here again
we don't I don't have any facts of the
situation that this is gonna go through
litigation been reported the SEC is also
looking into these two situations to see
if there's any violations of securities
law but a very interesting aspect of
this is whether or not these derivatives
contracts are securities under the law
the reason that the securities firms
have been able to set up their
over-the-counter affiliates outside of
SEC scrutiny because they are not
defined as being securities and the SEC
some of these contracts in the contracts
in question aren't just simple swaps
agreements they're leveraged agreements
we have options embedded in them and one
of the issues is does that option
component make that contract of security
and if it does were there violations of
the sales practice rules for securities
government policy if dealers were
required to disclose a wider range of
things to end-users entirely aside from
the legal question well I think partly
incumbent upon the buyers to ask
questions and depending on whether a
product security or not that certain
securities rules no your customer type
of little suitability rules that come
into play they if indeed these are
securities but I think they're it's a
it's a two-way responsibility here I
think it's a responsibility to the sale
to the sellers to provide
fair disclosure not certainly not
misleading disclosure but there's also I
think the responsibility the buyers part
to be asking suitability goes one step
further
however it's not only about disclosure
suitability places a burden on the
broker or the dealer to determine that
the party they are dealing with is
suitable for the transaction they're
proposing regardless of disclosure they
make that's a different thing altogether
and we have that log grows out of retail
brokers really and retail customers it's
a question of whether it should it's
equally applicable to let's say the
treasurer of IBM another question yeah
Colleen Brennan from BNA publications
mister Bothwell Doug Harris said OCC has
said recently that banks are holding a
great deal of structured notes and with
interest rates expected to go up again
do you think banks should be requiring
increased capital reserves
I mean regulators should be requiring
increased capital reserves and banks
well there are capital requirements on
banks based upon his face risks adjusted
basis what Cece is concerned about is
sort of the market risks of these
structured notes and interest rates
continuing right losses a man I have no
knowledge about the holdings of
structured notes by by the national
banks so it'd be very hard for me to say
hopefully that the examiners when
they're going and look at those
institutions are making judgments about
whether or not the institution is
holding sufficient capital
another question
well if that's it we will conclude on
the note that we have agreed to disagree
about some items and agreed to agree
about other items and I think we've
concluded that at least the crash will
probably not come tomorrow during
election day thank you all for coming
good night